in the last video you saw how the
attention model allows a neural network
to pay attention to only part of an
input sentence while generating a
translation much like a human translator
might
let's now formalize the intuition into
the exact details of how you would
implement an attention model so same as
in the previous video let's assume you
have an input sentence and you use a
bi-directional RNN or bi-directional GRE
or bi-directional STM to compute videos
on every words in practice gr use and LS
TMS are often used for this but maybe
I'll steal more common and so for the
for recurrence you would have a for
recurrence first time step activation
backward recurrence first time step
activation for the for recurrent second
time step activation backward and so on
there isn't one for all of them in this
a form with fifth time step a back with
fifth times there well you know we had a
a zero here technically we could also
have a I guess a backwards six as a
factor of all zero actually does a
vector of all zeros and then to simplify
the notation going forward at every time
step even though you have the features
computer from the for recurrence and
from the backward recurrence in a
bi-directional RNN I'm just going to use
a of T to represent both of these
concatenated together
so a T is going to be our feature vector
for time step T although to be
consistent with notation were used in a
second I'm going to call this T prime as
you're gonna use T prime to index into
the words in the French sentence next we
have our forward only so it's a single
Direction RNN which state
to generate the translation and so the
first time step it should generate y1
and this will have as input some context
C and if you want to index it with time
I guess you could write um c1 but
sometimes just write C without the
superscript 1 and this will depend on
the attention parameters so alpha 1 1
alpha 1 2 and so on
tells us how much attention and so these
alpha parameters tells us how much the
context will depend on the features
we're getting on the activations were
getting from the different time steps
and so the way we'll define the context
is there should be a way to some of the
features from the different times have
waited by these attention weights so
more formally the attention weights will
satisfy this that they're all be
non-negative so they'll be a zero
positive and they'll sum to one we'll
see you later how to make sure this is
true and we will have that the context
or the context at time one are often
drop that superscript
that's going to be sum over T prime all
the values of T prime of this weighted
sum of these um attention of these
activations so this term here are the
attention weights and this term here now
is comes from here and so alpha t t
prime is the amount of attention that y
t should pay to a of T prime
so in other words when you're generating
the teeth output words how much should
you be paying attention to the t price
input words so that's one step of
generating the output and then at the
next time step you generate the second
output and as a game done similarly
where now you have a new set of
attention weights they define a new way
to sum that generates a new context this
is also input and that allows you to
generate the second words only now yes
this way to sum becomes the context of
the second times that is somewhat of a t
prime alpha to T Prime so using these
context vectors c1 I'll just write that
back in C 2 and so on this network up
here looks like a pretty standard RNN
sequence with the context vectors as
output and we can just generate the
translation one word at a time we have
also defined how to compute the context
vectors in terms of these attention
waves and those features of the input
sentence so the only remaining thing to
do is to define how to actually compute
these attention ways let's do that on
the next slide so just a recap alpha t t
prime is the amount of attention you
should pay to a t prime when you're
trying to generate the teeth words in
the output translation so let me just
write down the formulas we talked about
how this works
this is formula you can use the compute
alpha T T prime which we're going to
compute these terms e TT Prime and then
use essentially of softmax to make sure
that these weights sum to 1 if you sum
over t prime so for every fixed value of
T these things sum to 1 if you're
summing over T prime and using this
software privatization
just ensures this property they sum to
one now how do you compute these factors
e well one way to do so is to use a
small new network as follows so s t
minus 1 was the neural network state
from the previous time step so here's
the network we have if you're trying to
generate YT then s T minus 1 was the
hidden state from the previous step
that's fed into s T and that's one input
to the very small neural network usually
one hidden layer neural network because
you need to compute these are locked and
then a T prime the features and from
time step T prime is the other input and
the intuition is if you want to decide
how much attention to pay to
deactivation at T prime well the things
that seems like it should depend the
mouse on is what is your own hidden
state activation from the previous time
step you don't have the current state
activation yet because the context fits
into this so you haven't computed that
but look at one of your hidden stages of
this errand and generating the output
translation and then for each of the
positions of each the worst look at
their features so it seems pretty
natural that alpha t t prime and e t t
prime should depend on these two
quantities but we don't know what the
function is
so one thing could do is just trim very
small neural network to learn whatever
this function should be and trust back
propagation trust gradient descent to
learn the right function and it turns
out that if you implement this whole
model and train it with gradient descent
the whole thing actually works this law
neural network does a pretty decent job
telling you how much attention YT should
pay to a t prime and this formula shows
that the attention weighs sum to one and
then as you chug along generating one
word at a time this neural network
actually pays attention to the right
parts of the input sentence
all this automatically using gradient
descent now one downside that this
algorithm is that it does take quadratic
time quadratic cost to run this
algorithm if you have TX worse than the
input and T Y worse than the output then
the total number of these attention
parameters is going to be T x times dy
and so this algorithm runs in quadratic
cost although in machine translation
applications where neither input nor
output sentences usually that long may
be quadratic constants actually
acceptable although there are some
research work on trying to reduce this
cost as well now so far I've been
describing the attention idea in the
context of machine translation without
going too much into detail this idea has
been applied to other problems as well
such as image captioning so in the image
captioning problem to toss this locally
picture and write a caption for that
picture so in this paper sight to the
bottom by Kevin chute Jimmy bar on Keros
Cameron show erinkoval rustle some food
and off Rich's MO and you're sure banjo
the author showed that you could have a
very similar architecture look at the
picture and pay attention only to parts
of the picture at a time while you're
writing a caption for a picture so if
you're interested in encourage you to
take a look at that paper as well and
you get to play with all this more in
the programming exercise whereas machine
translation is a very complicated
problem in the pro exercise you get to
implement and play up the attention
while yourself for the date
normalization problem so the problem in
putting a date like this there's
actually date of the Apollo moon landing
and normalizing it into standard formats
or a date like this and having a new
network a sequence a sequence model
normalize it to this format
by the way is the birth date of William
Shakespeare
also is believed to be and what you see
in the program exercises you can train
in your network to input dates in you
know any of these formats and have it
use an attention model to generate a
normalized format for these things one
other thing that sometimes fun to do is
to look at the visualizations of the
attention ways so here's a machine
translation example and here were
plotted in different colors the
magnitude of the different attention
ways I don't spend too much time on this
but you find that the corresponding
input and output words you find that the
attention weights will tend to be high
does suggesting that when it's
generating a specific word the output is
you know usually paying attention to the
correct words in the input and all this
including learning where to pay
attention when was all learned using
back propagation with an attention model
so that's it for the attention model
really one of the most powerful ideas in
deep learning I hope you enjoy
implementing and playing with some of
these ideas yourself later in this
week's pro exercises